[Musica]
ska
brusca
[Musica]
il toscano
scambio
[Musica]
è
[Applauso]
sono un tra surf un tracciatore di
percorsi prima di conoscere il parkour e
la bellezza che lo circonda frequentavo
le strade del mio quartiere barra
frequentavo da piccolo un mondo
ristretto la legge del quartiere per me
era la legge del mondo non conoscevo
altro al di fuori investito
continuamente di esempi sbagliati di
brutto
ogni giorno era immesso nella violenza e
nel vandalismo e tutto questo per me è
la normalità
la storia della mia famiglia quella che
accomuna purtroppo la maggior parte dei
ragazzi con la quale lavoro oggi
problemi economici parenti in carcere ma
comunque una famiglia che cerca di
allontanarti quanto più possibile da
questa realtà difficile
mia madre che purtroppo non riusciva ad
essere continuamente presente nella mia
fase adolescenziale per allontanarmi dal
quartiere decide di iscrivermi alle
scuole medie in un comune limitrofo a
barra purtroppo il circolo vizioso che
lei cercava di interrompere continuava
con piccole guerre fra noi ragazzi tra
minacce scontri e risse e soltanto
perché io ero di un altro quartiere alla
fine del terzo anno con ubi un ragazzo
michel questo mi parlava del parkour e
di questi ragazzi che saltavano che si
arrampicavano per la città e mi chiese
di andare con lui a vedere come
praticavano appena lividi
rimasi esterrefatto questi ragazzi che
saltavano con una potenza una leggerezza
assurda me ne innamora all'istante
all'inizio era complicato molto
complicato anche perché la abbastanza
cicciottello e la fatica si faceva
sentire ma poi con il tempo il mio corpo
si modificava sempre di più diventava
una macchina perfetta in equilibrio
perenne con la mente ormai era
allontanato dal quartiere iniziamo solo
ad allenarmi e a formarmi girando tutta
l'italia e l'europa prima come allievo e
poi come coach
un giorno un amico mi propone di fare un
video avevo 15 anni e quel video
all'epoca giro tutto il mondo è tutta la
comunità del parkour mondiale mi
conosceva
ma che cos'è il parkour il parkour è una
disciplina che nasce in francia nei
sobborghi parigini è una disciplina che
consiste nel partire da un punto a e
arrivare un punto b nel modo più
efficace ed efficiente possibile
allora disciplina che ti aiuta a
combattere le problematiche che sono
intorno a te è quelle dentro di te è
qualcosa che va ben oltre il singolo
gesto atletico ti aiuta a lavorare con
le paure con le insicurezze i miei occhi
ormai intorno a mi vedono un parco
giochi un luogo da vivere a 360 gradi da
ogni altezza sotto ogni punto di vista e
senza barriere architettoniche sono
privo soprattutto di schemi fisici e
mentali
facciamo un esempio se in questo momento
qui avvenisse non so un'emergenza un
qualcosa un problema la persona che si
sa salverebbe di più sarei io perché
perché grazie al parkour di grazie al
concetto di residenza presente nel
parkour posso adattarmi a qualsiasi via
di fuga ea qualsiasi cosa da un balcone
da una finestra
ma cosa voi inusuale dicevamo è un
giorno di topo su facebook un messaggio
di un certo giovanni savino che vide il
mio video su youtube e mi chiese di
partecipare al carnevale sociale che si
chiamava resilienza come acrobata barra
incontrai giovanni che era da poco
diventato presidente della cooperativa
sociale il tappeto di iqbal il tappeto
di iqbal prende il nome dai ball masiq
un bambino pakistano che si batte poi
venne ucciso dalla mafia dei tappeti in
pakistan negli anni 90 e giovanni con il
suo fascino la sua dote innata da
educatore sociale insieme alla realtà
che stava costruendo con i ragazzi del
quartiere mi insegnò che nessuno deve
mai dimenticare le origini e allora
inizia a frequentare questa realtà pazza
che faceva circo per strada che usava
l'arte come mezzo per andare avanti e
non me ne separa i più all'inizio mi
insegnarono lo yoga il teatro la
giocoleria l'acrobatica aerea in
principio ai ragazzi io non portavo il
parkour ma imparava a stare con loro
sotto la guida di giovanni e dei ragazzi
i soci della cooperativa con uno
strumento che non era per niente mio la
giocoleria e poi arrivò il teatro
montavamo degli spettacoli e partivamo
in giro per l'europa e per l'italia come
ancora oggi lo facciamo per raccogliere
fondi che ci permettono di lavorare e
formarci e portare avanti alla
cooperativa l'unica persona che crede
il mio parkour e giovanni che un giorno
mi propose di promise di poterla
trasferire come ha funzionato su di me
ai ragazzi del quartiere ma formando
mirela pedagogia nei vari aspetti che
questo lavoro di trincea richiede ma
perché il parkour nel sociale giovani mi
ha mostrato la pedagogia del rischio
positivo i ragazzi vivono la strada
barra con accezione negativa e rischiano
continuamente inconsapevolmente il
parkour è praticato in strada è
rischioso ma con un'accezione positiva
attraverso il lavoro di concentrazione
della mente e di potenziamento del corpo
aiutano ogni ragazzo a scoprire i propri
limiti all aiutiamo a superarli portando
l'attenzione su se stesso su se stesso
per esempio prendiamo ragazzo che sa su
un muro di due metri e 50 e deve
arrivare sul muro di un metro e 40 in
quel momento su quel muro di due metri e
50 si attiva rischio positivo per sé
perché il ragazzo è presente e
consapevole ed è nel qui ed ora essa che
grazie a tutto lavoro che ha fatto su se
stesso può riuscire a fare quel salto è
tutto questo insieme alla break dance al
circo alla probatica era al teatro da
david ha un posto ricco di opportunità e
di speranza allora la strada può essere
un'opportunità anche a barra il nostro
lavoro non è quello di creare grandi
alti artisti o grandi atleti ma è quello
di usare la bellezza impiantare la
bellezza in questi ragazzi
una bellezza che gli permette di vedere
qual è l'alternativa della realtà di
questo quartiere
grazie
[Applauso]